en combien de temps allez-vous résoudre
cet échec et mat en deux coups c'est
très haut blanc le grand maître fabien
libizessk a mis seulement 5 secondes à
trouver la solution mon cerveau va un
peu moins vite j'ai besoin de 30
secondes allez-vous faire mieux que nous
si vous les cherchez par vous-même je
vous laisse mettre pause et sinon voici
mon raisonnement d'abord j'ai pensé à
avoir tout de suite la bonne réponse en
jouant roi à 4 l'idée c'est de me cacher
derrière mes deux tours pour délivrer un
mat de l'escalier sauf qu'ensuite j'ai
réalisé que les noir pouvait capturer le
fouet avec la tour et sur roi B3 elle va
se sacrifier en bouclier et ça retarde
l'échéance et c'est attant seulement
trois coups c'est pas ce qu'on veut
retour à la position de départ et donc
comme souvent dans ces problèmes j'ai
cherché le coup le plus illogique et
m'est venu tout de suite à l'esprit tour
B6 avec la même idée d'aller me cacher
derrière ma tour pour faire un mat de
l'escalier et cette fois-ci s'il capture
mon fou alors il ne va pas pouvoir faire
bouclier puisque ma tour fait barrage
donc dans cette position les noirs sont
forcés de prendre notre tour et on
délivre un très joli échec etmat à la
découverte en bougeant not TR en
seulement deux coups mission accomplie